welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and a new Superman actor is
imminent according to a recent report
that listed David cornswick from Pearl
and the politician is in the running for
Kalel Clark Kent in the upcoming
Superman Legacy film this along with
Nicholas Holt and talks to play Lex
Luthor and Emma Mackey or Rachel rothnan
and talks for Lois Lane nothing has been
confirmed or locked in yet this is all
just still speculative but since
Superman Legacy will be the first of
James Gunn's DC Gods and Monsters slate
and a number of fans are still sore over
the partying of ways with Henry Cavill
from the Zack Snyder ERA this is one of
the most important casting decisions
Warner Brothers has faced in years and
whenever these casting reports start to
Bubble Up online there are a lot of
knee-jerk responses based on how an
actor looks or their reputation for past
roles and there's just not enough
insight into how the Hollywood Casting
process actually works in this case
James Gunn in the studio seem to be
looking back at the casting of
Christopher Reed in Richard Donner's
1978 Superman the movie and why that
worked so well and how this should be
less based on looks than on another
quality is it Dean is it America is it
being someone's son is it saying yes to
Brian Singer
so on Saturday May 13th The Hollywood
Reporter published that according to
multiple sources the short list for
Superman and Superman Legacy includes
David corinthwood from the Pearl and the
politician on Netflix along with two
other unknown contenders now Jacob
elordi who plays Nate Jacobs on Euphoria
did come up in this article but
apparently he never submitted himself
for the role British actors Tom Brittany
and Andrew Richardson were also in the
early mix now there's a belief that they
might want an American actor for Clark
Kent as every actor to play Superman
other than Henry Cavill has been
American even though of course the
character is an extraterrestrial from
Krypton actually back in 2019 David
quartz went told to Entertainment Weekly
about how he had previously had his
looks compared to Henry Cavill saying it
came to my attention before the internet
got a hold of me but my Pie in the Sky
ambition is definitely to play Superman
I would love to see somebody do an
upbeat throwback take on Superman love
the Henry Cavill dark and gritty take I
would love to see the next one be very
bright and optimistic now this same
article reports the studio heads
earmarks Nicholas Holt to play Lex
Luthor known of course for playing Hank
McCoy in the later X-Men films and roles
in Renfield the menu the great he's been
into some of his stuff Warner Brothers
was reportedly impressed with his work
as nux in Mad Max Fury Road and nearly
cast him and Matt Reese the Batman but
he lost the role to Robert Pattinson for
the role of Lois Lane this article lists
Emma Mackey from Netflix's sex education
in the upcoming Barbie film Richardson
actress Phoebe Denver and Samara weaving
from ready or not and scream 6 but the
standout audition apparently came from
Rachel Brosnahan from The Marvelous Mrs
maisel an amazing actress who seemed to
be playing Coy when the view asked her
about this recently the article says
that some sources say she's too old for
the role but she's 32 and David
courtswood is 29. why would that be a
problem come on Hollywood now writer
director James Gunn tweeted for all of
you asking I would never comment on who
is or isn't auditioning for a role
that's the actor's business only and
isn't something I'd make public unless
they did it first after the fact like
Glenn Howerton or Zachary Levi having
audition for Star-Lord and being top
choices for now only 1 person has been
cast in Superman Legacy and it isn't any
of the regular players in the Superman
world he ends with a mermaid Emoji which
is many wondering if he has cast the
character of Lori lamaris Clark's past
girlfriend from Metropolis University
who uses a wheelchair and a blanket to
hide her mermaid tail coming from a
different Kingdom in the continent of
Atlantis The Hollywood Reporter article
also said that there would be a screen
test around Memorial Day or early June
that will lock in the final choices and
some are now looking at David cord's win
and commenting on his similar appearance
to Henry Cavill for suggesting he might
need to put on some more muscle you know
all the great stuff people say when
actors are announced for these roles but
the deeper story here is corn Swift's
background and the general approach
James Gunn in the studio seemed to be
taking with Superman Legacy recently
James Gunn went on GQ and broke down his
top comic book movies and he listed at
number two Richard Donner's 1978
Superman the movie you know at the time
they did exactly what we're doing now
they're going through tons and tons of
actors to see who captures that Spirit
the thing they don't talk about much
when they talk about Christopher they
talk about his pureness his hope his
goodness they talk about you know the
way that he play is Clark as being so
different from the way he plays Superman
and how he can turn that on in an
instant but there's this playfulness
about Superman this when he's saving a
cat he's got that wry smile
nothing
am I frisky
long now
and that is one of the best parts of the
movie is the playfulness of Superman he
enjoys what he's doing he likes helping
human beings he likes saving them this
definitely follows the little bit of
information James Gunn has so far told
us about his plan for Superman Legacy a
plot synopsis that said the movie will
tell quote the story of Superman's
journey to reconcile his Kryptonian
Heritage with his human upbringing as
Clark Kent of Smallville Kansas he is
the embodiment of truth justice in the
American way Guided by human kindness in
a world that sees kindness as
old-fashioned and gun has tweeted that
he decided to write and direct the
project himself after turning it down
only after losing his father who didn't
understand him as a kid but supported
his love of comics and film and that he
found a way in by quote centering around
Superman's Heritage how both his
aristocratic Kryptonian parents and his
Kansas farmer parents inform who he is
and the choices he makes new rockstars
is doing an in-person live show most of
us have a background in improv sketch
and stand up and we've been working
behind the scenes for a long time to
develop a live new rock stars show and
now we're super excited to share it with
the world we've done panels at Comic
Cons and live streamed on YouTube but
this is a whole new ball game the kind
of show we've always wanted to do on May
26th in Los Angeles myself Tommy Jessica
and the new rock stars crew are gonna
escape the blue dungeon and get on stage
in front of an in-person audience
there's gonna be special guests
ridiculous comedy bits and exclusive
videos that we can never show on YouTube
it's live theater on a multiversal level
the in-person tickets for the event sold
out so we are also streaming the show as
a worldwide digital experience with our
partners at moment that link is also in
the description this is something we
hope to be doing a lot more of in the
future so leave a comment if you'd like
us to try to come to your city now I
have very much enjoyed the takes on
Superman by Henry Cavill and by Tyler
hecklin on the CW shows heklin didn't
have to audition for the role he proved
himself to Greg berlante from the role
he played on Teen Wolf on the CW and he
had a background as a youth actor he
played college baseball and you might
remember it was Tom Hanks son and bro to
Perdition Henry Cavill story is also
very interesting he was actually
attached to play Superman and the
Planned 2004 film Superman flyby from
director McGee but MCG backed out and
the project was given to Brian Singer
and became Superman Returns and singer
recast Capital with Brandon Ruth but
cavill's name had floated around Warner
Brothers for years in the early Arts he
actually auditioned to play Batman and
Christopher Nolan's Batman Begins
cavill's background we should note was
also as an athlete he played rugby at
the UK School Stowe where at age 16 he
actually met Russell Crowe who shot the
film Proof of Life at that school
Russell Crowe would go on to play his
Kryptonian father Jor L and Man of Steel
but Cavill despite his many talents is
very much a product of his time when it
comes to his superhero roles because
superhero actors have been expected to
be absolute units and lost are the days
of Christopher Reeve and Michael Keaton
with that kind of aw shucks charm and
the playfulness Boy Scout wholesomeness
and the physical clumsiness of Clark
Kent that Christopher Reed definitely
portrayed but was downplayed in Zack
Snyder's vision of this character in
this world I mean let's be honest the
real star of the Schneider verse has
always been Zack Snyder himself in a
storyboarding in the frame rate and the
color grading that he shoots these
characters in don't get me wrong I think
Zack Snyder's official genius and I'll
watch everything he makes but I think he
is the star of everything he makes but
look back at Christopher Reeve in his
background Christopher Reeve was a
Juilliard trained stage actor he's
actually roommates with Robin Williams
Christopher Reeve ate poorly he actually
fainted on the opening night of a
Broadway play a matter of gravity but
thanks in part to mentorship from
Catherine Hepburn and casting director
Lin stallmaster he got a meeting with
Richard Donner he later told a
biographer quote by the late 1970s the
masculine image had changed now it was
acceptable for a man to show gentleness
and vulnerability I felt that the new
Superman ought to reflect that
contemporary male image and that got him
the part he did later get in shape with
Star Wars actor David prowse to bulk up
but he never got into insanely shredded
bodybuilder shape it's just sad that
since then Hollywood is totally reverted
back to that Macho Norm where everyone
has to be a bodybuilder in fact one of
my favorite moments from Christopher
Reeve was a 1982 appearance on Late
Night with David Letterman where
Letterman asked him about working with
Marlon Brando and he went off on his
co-star limited that Marlon Brando used
to be a Hollywood acting Legend a leader
of their Community but began phoning it
in at this point in his career I I must
say I don't I don't say this to be
vicious but I don't worship at the altar
of Marlon Brando because I feel that
he's he's copped out in a certain way
he's no longer in the leadership
position that he could be he could
really be inspiring a whole generation
of actors and by continuing to work but
what happened is the Press loved him
whether he was good bad or indifferent
where people thought he was this sort of
institution no matter what he did so he
doesn't care anymore and I just think it
would be sad to be 53 whatever he is and
not give a damn that's all I just think
it's too bad that the man has kind of
been forced into the hostility
um that's but you wouldn't well he's
here tonight Chris
I mean there's definitely a Superman s
quality there here's the guy speaking
some truth in a way that you never see
on late night TV now where you never say
anything bad about anyone but he does it
in a way that rightly blames the
ecosystem of Hollywood and he begs his
acting hero to prove himself again take
back the torch and Lead the Way
similarly we should look at the real
life heroism and struggles of George
Reeves who played Superman in the 1950s
TV series and in the 2000 film
hollywoodland Ben Affleck dramatized a
real-life incident that happened to
George Reeves at a live show and it was
terrifying can I shoot you
Kenneth
why would you want to do something like
that so the Bullet bounces off
if you did shoot me
and the bullet bounced off I might
accidentally hit someone else
we don't want that to happen do we no so
I think that James Gunn gets that there
is a deeper Legacy to Superman's history
than the most fervent recent generation
of fans claim is the only way to do it
for what it's worth David cornswick like
Chris Marie also trained at Juilliard
the fact that they are looking at him at
all I think tells us that gun wants a
Superman who's more of a throwback Boy
Scout struggling to fit into an
otherwise cynical world I want to hear
your thoughts on this in the comments
below subscribe to our new channels the
Deep dive in the break room you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]